erstaunliches ist auf den fotos der
vorleser mission zum kometen 67 pc
gerasimenko zu den jetzt wurden sie
ausgewählt zum ersten mal haben
wissenschaftler beobachtet wie ein
kometenschweif entsteht also wie sich
der staub aus dem kometen löw und das
ist ziemlich spektakulär und natürlich
auch was die forschung dort über das
entstehen von leben im weltall aussagen
also herzlich willkommen bei klick vom
25 auf dem 60 pedro europe gerasimenko
auch liebevoll schule genannt scheint
die hölle los
ein astronaut würde einen aufenthalt
wahrscheinlich nicht sehr lange
überleben kurz noch mal zur einordnung
fury ist ein komet also ein eisbrocken
der ungefähr die größe eines berges hat
durchmesser kilometer dazu kommen noch
eine menge staub und gestein und jedes
mal wenn er der sonne nach wird sehr
viel von seiner materie durch die
sonnenwinde in den weltraum geblasen wir
werden bei solchen kometen in sonnennähe
deshalb einen schwarz kometen sind im
äußeren bereich unseres sonnensystems
entstanden und sie enthalten
wahrscheinlich die materie aus der unser
sonnensystem entstanden sprich wie
könnten eine entscheidende rolle bei der
entstehung von leben auf der erde
gespielt haben sein ende 2014 umkreis
die raumsonde rosetta tour und hat sogar
einen länder die sonne viele dort
abgeworfen es war eine sensation
auch wenn viele etwas unglücklich im
schatten eines vorsprungs aufsetzte und
deshalb nur wenig energie zur verfügung
hatte war aber die erste landung einer
sonde auf einem kometen jetzt wurden
aber bilder von rosetta ausgewertet und
die sind wirklich sehr schnell auf dem
kometen rumpel ist nämlich gewaltig der
stau für den schweiß wird offensichtlich
nicht nur staubkörnchen verstaut
körnchen vom kometen gewählt sondern es
ist eine menge los
nur eins war bisher sicher dass ein von
kometen geht durch die erwärmung durch
die sonne vom fetten sofort in den
gasförmigen zustand über wenn es
verdammt reifen immer auf staubpartikel
mit sich in die coma eine staub auf
affäre um den kometen der dann das
material für den schweiß bildet wenn
sich der komet aber der sonne nähert
steigert sich die aktivität sehr
deutlich und die aufnahmen jetzt gezeigt
haben geht das quasi explosionsartig
vorsicht rosetta konnte sogar den
abbruch eines cliff dokumentieren durch
den eine helle eisfläche freigelegt
wurde dabei donnerten rund 120000 von
material in die tiefe und 500 bis 1000
tonnen staub wurden ins all geschleudert
andere fotos zeigen wie ein lastwagen
großer 130 tausend tonnen schwerer
brocken über den kometen wandert bewegt
durch mehrere gas ausdrückt tui sieht ja
aus wie eine ente war vermutlich daher
rührt dass er bei der kollision zweier
kometen entstanden ist und zudem scheint
er über kurz oder lang wieder für werden
rohwetter konnte spalten an seinem hals
fotografieren die wahrscheinlich früher
oder später zum auseinanderbrechen von
schumi führen die rosetta mission ist
dadurch ein riesiger erfolg noch wenn er
nicht alle fotos ausgewertet so
verdichtet sich durch die erkenntnisse
der mit lohn die vermutung dass das
leben durch kometen auf die erde
gekommen wenn könnte zwar konnten keine
organismen gefunden werden wobei auch
die messinstrumente dafür kaum
ausgereicht hätten aber es wurden
wichtige bausteine des lebens wie das
protein und organische moleküle wie
formaldehyd und etan gefunden damit wird
auch die theorie des baseballs also des
weltraum sperma
allerdings spricht vieles dafür dass sie
sich das leben selbst ist also gar
nichts hören das dann zwischen den
welten transportiert besondern dass die
bausteine des lebens durch kometen auf
die erde kam spannend bleibt es also und
ich bin wirklich gespannt wann wir
wirklich wissen wie leben im weltall
entsteht und damit wie hoch die
wahrscheinlichkeit für außerirdisches
leben ist auch auf der erde wurde dazu
ja jetzt spektakuläres gefunden
außerirdisches leben so könnte es sich
entwickeln liegt auch dieses video
wenn ihr mehr darüber wissen will drückt
mehr hier ein abo aufs auge wenn ihr
nicht verpassen wollte und gebt mir
anschließend noch unbedingt bei ihnen
einen auf die glocke und jetzt kurz und
bündig gesang bleibt